die atomkraft ist wo das gefährlichste
was menschen je erfunden haben auch
deswegen geben sie in deutschland als
auslaufmodell doch trotz der zahlreichen
risiken die die atomkraft mit sich
bringt planen nasa ingenieure jetzt
kernreaktoren auf den mars und mond zu
schicken
doch eigentlich wollen wir diese fremden
planeten doch entdecken und erkunden und
nicht zerstören was genau das nasa
projekt qi low power plant welche
folgenschweren konsequenten der ganze
plan haben könnte jetzt endlich zum
teil zu wissen
herzlich willkommen
bei der erforschung des weltalls gibt es
ein großes problem dass
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
bislang nicht wirklich zufriedenstellend
lösen konnten mit welcher
zuverlässigen transportwegen und
ergiebigen energiequelle können wir
weltraumstationen mit strom versorgen
bei der es der internationalen
raumstation geht das prima mit
photovoltaik also sonnenenergie ist ja
auch nahe an der sonne aber woanders ist
das nicht der fall müssen oft nicht nur
die wissenschaftlichen geräte die
bemannten station sondern auch die
erkundungs fahrzeuge mit strom versorgt
werden und den brauchen sie nicht zu
knapp die navis dabei schon länger auf
kernenergie der mars rover curiosity
wird beispielsweise durch radionuklid
batterien betrieben einen klumpen
plutonium 238 in dessen inneren ständig
atomkerne zerfallen entsteht wärme und
liefert einige hundert das entspricht in
etwa dem energiebedarf eines normalen
staubsaugers ihr könnt euch denken dass
das für große vorhaben im weltraum
natürlich nicht reicht die vision vom
forscherteams weltweit mobile
kernreaktoren die die stromversorgung
einer marke oder mondstation
sicherstellen würden und diese idee
wird jetzt konkreter denn ingenieure und
ingenieurinnen der nasa wollen ab
september einen mini reaktor in der
wüste nevadas testen der später mal an
bord einer rakete ins all fliegen
könnte das projekt mit dem namen qi low
power läuft schon seit drei jahren und
die nasa meinte tatsächlich ernst für
die entwicklung des 1 kilowatt prototyps
gibt die us-weltraumbehörde wohl 15
millionen us-dollar aus technik soll der
gut drei meter lange und 1 5 tonnen
schwere mini rechners folgender marken
funktionieren sein zylinder aus einer
uran malt den regierung wird von einem
neutron strahl getroffen was dazu führt
dass die darin enthaltenen uran-235
atomkerne gespalten werden dadurch
entsteht wärme die dann in elektrischen
strom umgewandelt wird die nasa
ingenieure erhoffen sich dadurch eine
leistung von bis zu zehn kilowatt zum
vergleich ein atomkraftwerk kommt auf
etwa eine million kilowatt leistung der
mini reaktor der nasa würde also nur
ein bruchteil davon leisten doch das
forscherteam will einfach mehrere
minimaler bereitstellen die dann
gemeinsam
die stromversorgung verschiedener
missionen sicherstellen könnten ein
konzeptpapier der nasa verrät dass die
reaktoren darauf angelegt sein sollen
mindestens zehn jahre lang energie zu
liefern
ob das alles so erfolgreich wird wie
sich die nasa das vorstellt ist aber
äußerst fraglich bisherige tests mit
kernreaktor sind gescheitert
beispielsweise die atom öfen der
sowjetunion und auch bei den 500 watt
reaktor der nasa namens net 10a der 65
in den erdorbit gestartet war versagte
die elektronik bereits nach rund 40
tagen auch immer wieder also im all
seine bahnen und wird in zukunft
irgendwann mit werner radioaktiven
fracht auf die erde stürzen doch ganz
abgesehen von den technologien die bei
weitem noch lange nicht ausgereizt sind
bin ich etwas irritiert von dieser idee
der nase grundsätzlich von dieser idee
auf der erde ist die atomkraft ein
auslaufmodell zu hoch sind die gefahren
und risiken die kernkraft mit sich
bringt nach jahrzehnten der friedlichen
nutzung der kernkraft liegen wir immer
noch nicht wohin mit dem extrem
gefährlichen müll stattdessen planen
wir das gefährlichste überhaupt was
wir menschen gefunden haben auch noch im
weltall zu exportieren also kaum
beginnen wir mit der regelmäßigen
raumfahrt exportieren wir erst mal den
schlimmsten abfall den wir produzieren
können ins weltall
obwohl so unser ziel sein sollte die uns
noch unbekannten planeten zu entdecken
und auch in irgendeiner art und weise
verantwortung dafür zu übernehmen und
eben nicht einer menschengemachten
gefahr auszusetzen und auch wir hier auf
der erde würden im fall der fälle
probleme bekommen kaum auszudenken wenn
die rakete mit dem radioaktiven material
an bord einen fehlstart hinlegt und das
verseuchte material in die luft oder das
meer gelangt wenn es zur atomkraft dem
welt erneut gibt dann der vater
persönlich hierbei ging für wenn ihr
kein video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird
mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den genau auf die glocke hier geht
es weiter mit revolution der raumfahrt
nächster schritt der evolution
da geht es um die absolut bahnbrechenden
entwicklungen im bereich der raumfahrt
sehr sehr spannend also nicht verpassen
und brauch klicken und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran